[Musique]
soyez pas timides qui dans cette salle
pense qu'il est possible de changer sa
vie en disant en levant la main
qui pense que c'est possible en disant
waouh
ok tu penses que c'est possible
maintenant de changer sa vie en
seulement 5 ans
3 ans
OK
moi j'ai changé ma vie en trois ans et 2
mois
et je vais vous raconter ça tout de
suite il est 12h45 j'ai 7 ans
après la cantine je rejoins pour la
première fois le club d'échecs de
l'école
j'y rejoint cette intervenant qu'il
dégage quelque chose de très agréable il
a repéré en classe que j'étais intrigué
par son jeu
alors il me demande de le mettre en
échec et mat avec deux tours contre son
seul roi
j'essaye je lui donne un échec un autre
encore un autre mais je tourne en rond
après 5 minutes il me donne la clé
tu sais Joachim au lieu de donner des
échecs sans cesse tu dois utiliser une
des tours pour couper le roi regarde
je découvre mon premier match de
l'escalier
je suis à la fois émerveillé et très
très frustré de ne pas y avoir pensé par
moi-même quelques semaines plus tard
c'est d'échec de la ville où je me rends
pour la première fois
j'y retrouve Yannick ce sera mon
entraîneur jusqu'à mes 20 ans
j'ai gagné le tournoi de l'école et je
suis plutôt bon aux échecs rapidement
parmi les meilleurs français
je participe même en 2005 au championnat
du monde des moins de 12 ans les
résultats sont prometteurs
mais moi ce que je veux c'est être
médecin
et c'est normal
mais mes parents eux
n'ont pas eu la chance de faire des
études ma mère a commencé à travailler à
17 ans dans un hypermarché et elle y est
restée toute sa vie
mon père arrivé d'Inde en France à 14
ans a dû très vite aller au charbon lui
aussi
il a travaillé à la chaîne dans
l'industrie automobile
pas étonnant que je sois programmé pour
faire de longues études
finalement c'est pas la fac de médecine
que je rejoins mais j'intègre une prépa
HEC c'est gratuit et ça va m'ouvrir
toutes les portes
je suis toujours parmi les meilleurs
français aux échecs et parfois je me
prends à rêver de prendre une année
sabbatique enchaîner les tournois une
vie de joueur pro
mais impossible de gagner sa vie comme
ça
déjà je suis pas assez fort et puis même
il faut que je fasse un vrai métier que
je gagne de l'argent alors j'intègre une
école de commerce
j'emprunte 30 000 euros tout le monde le
fait ça doit être probablement rentable
et j'opte pour le double diplôme CCA
contrôle comptabilité audit est-ce que
ça m'intéresse
franchement pas du tout
mais c'est le parcours le plus difficile
et je me dis que probablement ça va me
permettre de gagner beaucoup d'argent je
me demande quand même à ce moment-là
jusqu'où je peux aller aux échecs
et au moment de faire ce stage de trois
mois pour voir un ami auto-entrepreneur
de me faire une convention de stage et
je passe l'été à m'entraîner et à jouer
des tournois
je joue trois mois aux échecs et à la
fin de l'été j'ai gagné 150 points
j'obtiens le titre de Maître field et
j'intègre le top 150 français
et le pire c'est que je sais que je peux
aller encore plus loin j'ai qu'une envie
c'est de continuer à jouer
mais en septembre
[Musique]
il faut que j'aille bosser
j'ai signé mon premier CDI dans un grand
cabinet
je serai auditeur financière alors je
suis là pour deux choses
je veux rendre fier mes parents
et deux je veux devenir libre
financièrement le plus vite possible
pour pouvoir rejouer aux échecs après
quelques mois mes parents sont fiers
c'est très bien
moi
je me demande vraiment ce que je fais là
je travaille beaucoup du matin au soir
un travail où je comprends pas tout ce
que je fais la pression est énorme parce
que les deadlines sont les mêmes mais
les équipes sont réduites de moitié
comme je vous dis je fais tout le plus
vite possible à un moment je comprends
même pas ce que je fais mais je le fais
et visiblement tout le monde est content
comme ça le pire
[Musique]
c'est que la plupart de mes managers
sont catastrophiques
je me souviendrai toujours cette mission
d'audit premier jour avec un manager que
je risque d'avoir plusieurs mois
à l'heure du déjeuner
comment ça m'expliquer que ça risque
d'être compliqué d'aller déjeuner on n'a
pas le temps
à 20h le soir au moment de rentrer
chez mes affaires et lui attrape la
carafe de café froides du matin et se
lancer cul sec devant moi comme pour me
montrer l'exemple
deux ans plus tard je suis auditeur
senior mon téléphone n'arrête pas de
sonner chaque manager me demande de
finir en vitesse ce petit truc pour lui
t'inquiète pas je joue ça va te prendre
cinq minutes
j'en peux plus le bon côté c'est que mes
parents sont très fiers ma mère me voit
rentrer systématiquement en costume elle
est ravie mon père je lui dis que si je
reste 10 ans dans cette boîte je vais
probablement gagner 10 000 euros par
mois
tout est parfait mais ce que je peux
continuer à tenir ce stress
et ce management encore longtemps
bon pendant ces trois ans les échecs ne
m'ont pas quitté bien au contraire plus
ma déception du monde de l'entreprise
grandit plus ma passion pour les échecs
se renforce à chaque mission d'audit
j'emporte avec moi mon manuel de finale
le livre de voredski que j'étudie le
soir avec l'énergie qu'il me reste avec
mon salaire d'auditeur j'embauche même
un entraîneur avec qui je travaille une
fois par semaine
je continue à jouer des tournois en
région parisienne les weekends
mais malgré tous mes efforts donc
classement
je passe de la 150e place
à 250e français
[Musique]
octobre 2017 je refuse d'abdiquer je
pose une semaine de congé sans solde je
rassemble mes dernières économies et je
m'envole pour un très fort tournoi au
Cap d'Agde il faut que je regagne des
points je sais que je vais y arriver
tout se passe normalement jusqu'à la
rendre 4
où j'affronte un très jeune joueur de 10
ans seulement
j'ai un peu
la partie se passe bien j'ai le dessus
sur mon jeune adversaire je sens que je
suis plus fort que lui rapidement il se
retrouve acculé et j'ai une attaque de
maths je devrais pouvoir gagner le
problème c'est que j'ai plus beaucoup de
temps pour
mais je continue à bien jouer je joue
bien je joue bien et au moment de
trouver le coup de grâce j'ai quelques
secondes
je joue
et merde
je me suis trompé
la situation s'inverse
ma position est maintenant sans espoir
j'ai mal au ventre
j'abandonne
le lendemain
je joue à nouveau un joueur moins bien
classé que moi
et je peux encore
5h du mat je suis dans ma chambre
d'hôtel
j'ai l'estomac noué j'ai honte
je décide d'abandonner le tournoi et de
rentrer à Paris
presque un an plus tard
après un nouvel échec tournoi à
Barcelone mon classement est au plus bas
je ne suis même plus dans le Top 500
français
mais c'est là
que la chance va frapper une première
fois maintenant
j'y revois comme si c'était hier je suis
au 26e étage de la tour mahjonga à la
défense dans cette minuscule salle de
réunion et je suis en train de bosser
sur mon PC
et là je reçois un message je suis
surpris c'est accepte de l'ordre un
grand maître français
ok on a un peu discuté à Barcelone mais
ce prof français n'écrit jamais
je lis son message
Jo tu m'avais parlé de tes envies de
reconversion un poste d'entraîneur à
temps partiel se libère dans mon club
j'ai tout de suite pensé à toi ça sera
moins bien payé que ton boulot par
contre
je relis le message
et si c'était ma porte de sortie
mais que vont bien mes parents
ce que c'est vraiment raisonnable
après quelques minutes j'ai ce feu qui
brûle en moi impossible de me sortir
cette idée de la tête c'est décidé on y
va je vais le poursuivre ce
j'ai démissionné et je commence ma
nouvelle vie j'ai libéré toutes mes
matinées pour m'entraîner aux échecs et
l'après-midi je donne trois à quatre
heures de cours ce rythme comparé à
l'audit pour moi c'est comme des
vacances je redécouvre même la lumière
du jour
tout est parfait j'ai enfin la chose qui
m'avait le plus manqué pour passer pro
du temps bien vite pourtant je me rends
compte que tout n'est pas si simple
après tout je gagne seulement 1200 euros
et avec cette emprunt étudiant sur le
dos il va falloir que je gagne plus
d'argent
le premier mois j'ai pas le choix je
fais le livreur deliveroo pour payer les
factures
mon entourage est perplexe personne ne
comprend ce que je fais il y a quelques
semaines j'étais au chaud en Costa et là
je me retrouve à arpenter les rues de
Paris à vélo pour quelques euros
mais moi je sais ce que je fais et je
sais pourquoi je le fais
je suis en mission
rapidement grâce à mon réseau j'arrive à
trouver un élève pour des cours
particuliers puis un autre et très vite
j'arrive même à gagner en donnant des
cours d'échecs ce que je gagne en audit
le problème c'est qu'à 25 euros de
l'heure je sens que je m'épuise
quelques mois plus tard je commence à me
faire un monde en tant qu'entraîneur et
je commence à me faire apprécier
j'arrive à augmenter un peu mes tarifs
et à me libérer un peu de temps
mais c'est toujours pas assez
[Musique]
patience
octobre 2020 le covid nous frappe
et je suis coincé chez moi
alors je sais que pour beaucoup le
confinement a été quelque chose de
difficile presque insupportable
mais n'oubliez pas une chose
moi je suis un joueur d'échec être
contraint de rester enfermé chez moi
tout le temps c'est ma vie rêvée
à ce moment-là le jeu de la dame sort
sur Netflix et les échecs ont une
popularité incroyable et c'est là dans
ce contexte
que la chance va frapper une deuxième
fois n'importe
il y a ce club parisien qui organise un
tournoi un peu spécial il s'agit de
jouer des Blitz des parties très rapides
en commentant sa pensée devant des
spectateurs
alors moi j'ai toujours été plutôt
extraverti pour un joueur d'échec et
puis je suis plutôt pédagogue alors
c'est l'exercice parfait pour moi je
m'inscris je
mais je me fais sortir à l'issue d'un
match acharné
pourtant
l'organisateur me contacte Joachim
c'est la plus grosse audience depuis le
début de l'événement
certains spectateurs m'écrivent même
pour me remercier pour le moment passer
à ce moment là je me dis mais jour
pourquoi tu te lancerais pas dans le
streaming du jeu d'échec en ligne ni une
ni deux j'achète un micro une caméra et
je lance mon premier live sur twitch bon
au départ c'est pas facile mon setup il
est pourri je suis en partage de
connexion sur mon téléphone et personne
ne me regarde
ma mère ma sœur mon frère et puis j'ai
le PC qui est dans la chambre
bon je demande
au licencier des clubs d'échecs qui me
intervient de regarder les live et
j'arrive à monter à 15 20 viewers
mais pendant plusieurs mois
ça se stagne
cette période va être vraiment difficile
le rythme redevient plus soutenu que
celui qu'il était en audit
les matins je lance des lives sur twitch
les après-midi je donne des cours
d'échec dans des écoles le soir je donne
des cours particuliers d'échecs dans des
clubs
combien de temps je vais pouvoir tenir
après quelques mois je vais franchir une
étape qui va être absolument cruciale je
vais publier ma première vidéo sur
YouTube
alors moi j'aurais jamais pensé ça quand
mes potes étaient tous sur insta moi
j'étais encore sur facebook j'ai jamais
été branché réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui
c'est moi des gens quotidiens je lui dis
tu as pensé à faire des vidéos sur Tik
Tok c'est vraiment
cette première vidéo qui va qui va tout
chambouler
après Joachim auditeur
Joachim prof d'échec c'est une troisième
vie qui commence Joachim youtuber
bientôt 2 ans que cette première vidéo a
été publiée sur YouTube
aujourd'hui je ne donne plus aucun cours
d'échec particulier
aujourd'hui j'ai quitté le club dans
lequel j'étais salarié et j'ai troqué
mon SMIC
aujourd'hui à chaque fois que je lance
un live sur twitch j'ai en moyenne entre
200 et 300 spectateurs qui me regardent
il y a deux semaines j'ai même lancé mon
propre club d'échec en ligne aujourd'hui
j'aime vraiment ma vie et mon travail
je n'ai toujours pas réalisé mon rêve de
devenir grand maître mais j'y travaille
chaque jour et je partage ce projet avec
les plus de 50 000 abonnés qui me
suivent sur les différents réseaux
sociaux et avec vous maintenant ce soir
quand j'étais petit
j'ai dit à mes parents que je serai
médecin c'était
la moindre des choses et c'était la
manière à moi de les rendre fier
je ne suis pas devenu médecin
mais j'ai tenu ma promesse de faire de
longues études
je me suis retrouvé malheureusement en
haut de cette tour
à vivre la vie d'un pion bloqué sur une
case
j'ai longtemps cru que c'était ma
décision et c'est bien plus tard que
j'ai compris qu'en fait ça n'était pas
vraiment
alors je regrette pas du tout mon
parcours c'est pas Élodie financier
m'ont appris énormément à m'exprimer à
m'organiser à prendre confiance en moi
alors je vais pas vous dire ce soir que
ça va être facile
il y aura des moments compliqués
des moments de doute
d'incompréhension
votre entourage ne vous suivra pas
toujours
parfois vous aurez même l'impression de
reculer ou que la montagne a franchir
est trop haute
mais si vous avez quelque chose en vous
que vous voulez faire et qui vous fait
vibrer même si a priori on ne peut pas
en faire un vrai métier
même si ça semble stupide aux autres
s'il vous plaît ne lâchez pas
continuer
essayez trompez-vous plusieurs fois même
s'il le faut
mais s'il vous plaît
continuer d'avancer
au final
difficile de se perdre en chemin
lorsqu'on décide d'être soi-même
[Applaudissements]